হ
‏struggle
[Silence]
ச
رمضان سبحانه
وتعالى جاب
[Silence]
احد الله
make other days and also days
‏and write that as a
for
ask to make from the people people who
unite hearts and not
divs to make the of unit and
notنا توليت وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت وكنا
واصرف عنا برحمتك شر ما قضيت
انك تقضي ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يزل من
واليت ولا يعز من عاديت تباركت ربنا
تعاليت اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر
لنا ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا وان لم
تغفر لنا ترحمنا لكن من الخاسرين اللهم
انك عفو كريم تحب العفو فاعفو عنا اللهم
انك عفو كريم تحب العفاع عنا اللهم انك
عفو كريم تحب العفاعفو عنا اللهم انصر
اسلام المسلمين اللهم انصر اسلام المسلمين
اللهم انصر اخوانا المستضعفين في فلسطين
وغزه وفي سودان
وفي الصين وفي برما وفي كشمير وفي هند وفي
كل مكان اللهم ايدم جنودك لا يعلم جنودك
الا انت اللهم عز جارك وجل ثناؤك وتقدست
اسماؤك اللهم لا يرد امرك ولا يحتن جندك
سبحانك وبحمدك اللهم عيد المسجد الاقصى
الى رحاب المسلمين اللهم عيد المسجد
الاقصى الى رحاب المسلمين اللهم عيد
المسجد الاقصى الى رحاب المسلمين وارزقنا
فيه صلاه القبلمت اللهم اعتق رقابنا من
النار ورقاب والدينا وذريتنا وازواجنا
وارحامنا وامهاتنا
وابائنا ومشا مشايخنا واصدقانا وادخلنا
الجنه مع الابرار يا عزيز يا غفار اللهم
يا سامع الصوت ويا سابق الفوت و كاس عزام
لحن بعد الموت اغفر لجميع الموتى المسلمين
الذين شهدك بالوحدانيه ونبيك بالرساله
وماتوا على ذلك اللهم اغفر لهم وارحمهم
وعافه واعفو عنهم واكرم نزلهم وس مدخلهم
واغسلهم منماء الثلج والبرد ونقه من
الذنوب والخطايا كما ينقى الثوب الابيض من
الدنس ومتعنا اللهم اللهم باسماعنا
ابصارنا وقواتنا ابدا ما حييتنا واجعلهما
وارث منا واجعل ثارنا على من ظلمنا
وانصرنا على من عادانا ولا تسلط عيننا
بذنوبنا من لا خافك فينا ولا
يرحمنا اللهم نسالك خير كله عاجله واجله
وما علمنا منه ولا لم نعلم ونعوذ بك من شر
كله عاجله واجله وما علمنا منه ولا لم
نعلم اللهم نسالك خير ما سالك عبدك نبيك
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم ونعوذ بك شر ما
عاذ بك عبدك ونبيك محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم اللهم نسالك الجنه اللهم نسالك الجنه
اللهم نسالك الجنه ونعوذ بك من النار
ونعوذ بك من النار ونعوذ بك من النار
وقولا وعملا ونسالك واليه من قول من عمل
نسالك ان تجعل كل قضاء قضيه لنا يا خير يا
رب
العالمين ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار وقنا عذاب
القبر وكنا عذاب جهنم وكنا شر فتنه ماحيا
الممات وكنا شر فتنه مسيح الدجال ربنا
تقبل منا انك السميع عليه وتوب عليه يا
مولانا التواب الرحيم صلى الله على محمد
وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين برحمتك رحم
الراحمين اللهم امين وعيدكم مبارك
[Silence]
ان شاء
الله السلام
[Silence]
السلام
الله السلام عليكم السلام
[Silence]
شاء
السلام عليكم عيد مبارك
‏Thank
[Silence]
الله
الحمد
لله عيد مبارك
يلا
[Silence]
وين
خلاص يا
ابراهيم حسن
[Silence]
الحمد
جزاك الله
عنايا ونعم
ان شاء
‏Tomas
ا